second débat consacré à ce défilé
militaire à moscou au discours de
vladimir poutine l'armée russe glorifié
et l'histoire de la seconde guerre
mondiale réécrite comme si les
soviétiques avaient été les seules à
vaincre le nazisme ccist
sur la place rouge de moscou ce 9 mai
devait être une démonstration de force
mais la commémoration de la victoire
russe sur les nazis s'est finalement
transformée en une parade militaire sans
faste ni triomphalisme
onze mille hommes des dizaines de chars
mais pas de défilé aérien et pas non
plus de discours guerrier du président
vladimir poutine
plus mesuré que prévu il est de notre
devoir de garder la mémoire de ceux qui
ont écrasé le nazisme qui nous ont légué
d'être vigilants
et de tout faire pour que l'horreur
d'une guerre mondiale ne se reproduise
plus ni apporte à la hausse dans son
allocution le président russe esseulé
sur la scène internationale depuis le
début de la guerre en ukraine s'est
justifié auprès de ses concitoyens son
pays a tout fait pour éviter la
confrontation avec son voisin mais s'est
résigné à l'attaqué car il faisait face
à une menace d'agression une menace
absolument inacceptable pour notre
sécurité a été systématiquement créer et
en plus directement à nos frontières
une cérémonie utilisée par le président
comme outil de propagande auprès de son
peuple pourtant sur le terrain en
ukraine son armée est enlisée depuis
deux mois et demi dans le conflit elle
concentre ses attaques dans l'est du
pays où une bombe russe a touché hier
une école du loup banks en faisant 60
morts
voilà les symboles de cette journée du 9
mai en russie mais aussi en ukraine
évidemment on en débat tout de suite
avec laure mandeville bonsoir bienvenue
ou êtes vous reporter au figaro ancien
correspondant du journal à à moscou et
washington auteurs de ce livre les
révoltés d'occident c'est aux éditions
de l'observatoire j'accueille elle ment
à le huer ou bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
sociologue maître de conférences
maîtresse de conférences à l'université
paris-x nanterre spécialiste de la
russie vous aviez publié quelques années
on est en plein dans le thème culture
militaire et patriotisme dans la russie
d'aujourd'hui
jacques également pascal boniface
directeur de l'institut de relations
internationales et stratégiques votre
livre la géopolitique tout simplement et
aux éditions eyrolles laetitia cru pas
et rester à mes côtés quelques chiffres
pour pour commencer autour de ceux de ce
défilé
selon l' agence de presse russe interfax
onze mille soldats 131 unités de
matériel militaire et puis on annonçait
77 avions et hélicoptères on annoncé
puisque le défilé aérien a été annulé
officiellement à cause d'eux des
conditions météos laure mandeville et
céistes ces images dont on vient de voir
là dans le sujet de cécile 6 où elles
sont destinées d'abord aux russes faut
bien avoir ça en tête je dirais aux deux
02 c'est à dire je pense qu'il ya
vraiment une volonté de
démonstration de force on sentait
presque une sorte de satisfaction de
vladimir poutine a regardé espèce de mer
de 2
d'uniformes en fait comme une sorte de
oui c'est ça de vagues qui avançaient
devant ses yeux qui déployait la
puissance en fait ce qu'il veut être la
puissance de l'armée russe et moi ce que
je retiendrai c'est c'est le contraste
en fait entre la démonstration de force
et c'est vrai qu'à l'est toujours
absolument spectaculaire les uniformes
le kart un impeccable de ceux de ce
défilé la puissance des équipements qui
sont qui sont comment dire déployer et
de l'autre côté ce que nous savons ce
que nous avons vu ce que nous voyons se
dérouler sous nos yeux qui est au
contraire le spectacle des ratés des
failles le visage je dirais lui bien
réel et grimaçant de cette armée russe
qui au fond comme toutes les armes et le
miroir de l'état russe de ces failles de
ces corruptions de ses compromissions de
sa brutalité et le miroir de la société
russe aussi qui s'est un peu perdue
comme on le voit dans les massacres qui
sont aujourd'hui permettrait
effectivement à l'euro c'est 75 jours de
guerre ont écorné quand même l'image de
la puissance de l'armée russe est ce qu
est ce que finalement vous qu'il l'avait
étudié étudient aussi la place de
peut-être des des uniformes dans la
société russe aujourd'hui ces acomptes
j'entendais ce matin qu'on voit de plus
en plus de d'enfants de jeunes enfants
en uniforme ya toute cette propagande à
l'oeuvre est ce que vous avez été
surprise depuis soixante quinze jours
des difficultés rencontrées par l'armée
russe alors je vais dire plusieurs
choses d'une part par rapport aux
difficultés de l'armée russe moi je ne
suis pas une spécialiste du militaire
pense que tout le monde a été un
finalement un petit peu surpris par
effectivement la caractère
d'impréparation qui révélait aussi cette
corruption massive à l'intérieur de
l'armée quand même temps on connaît il
ya eu des grandes affaires de corruption
qui ont été d'ailleurs dénoncée par le
pouvoir russe lui-même ces dernières
années la baronne services etc donc
effectivement ça l'a montré avec plus
d'éclat 1 l'état finalement pas si
glorieux de cette arme et qu'on avait
cru en effet complètement renaît de ses
cendres depuis le début des années 2000
une capacité d'exportation d'armements
tout à fait réelle je pense que
effectivement par ailleurs la russie
dispose manifestement d'armement de
dernier cri c'est en tout cas elle elle
prétend le faire et on peut imaginer que
c'est en partie le cas mais elle a un
côté des soldats qui sont
pas équipés m'a nourri avec des rations
périmés
envoyée au casse pipe sans savoir où ils
vont des soldats dont on sait maintenant
il ya énormément d'études là qui
paraissent sur le recrutement disons
sociologie peut voir j'ai en tout cas
d'un certain nombre de républiques avec
des minorités ethniques dans la
fédération de russie qui fournissent le
gros contingent des soldats et en
particulier de ceux qui meurent sur le
front est aussi de ceux en partie en
tout cas de ceux qui commettent ces
crimes de guerre par contre ça alors je
ne peux pas vraiment dire que ça nous
étonne complètement et je pense que leur
monde il le sait aussi bien que moi nous
on a quand même assisté à l'arrivée au
pouvoir de vladimir poutine à l'automne
99 avec des crimes de guerre commis en
tchétchénie qui sont je dirais de même
nature que les crimes de guerre qui sont
commis aujourd'hui donc finalement 7e
c'est pas pour dire que c'est qu'il se
passe en ukraine depuis le 24 février
était contenu dans
octobre ou novembre 99 ou mars 2000 mais
en tout cas que les faits sont là pour
montrer que c'était déjà possible à ce
moment là pascal boniface cette date du
du neuf mais là on l'a beaucoup entendu
dans nos débats en disant qu'il y avait
un enjeu que vladimir poutine voulait
afficher une victoire militaire ce jour
là on peut finalement il n'a pas pu le
faire ce soir est ce que cette date
comme certains le disent peut-être
plutôt du côté russe était une
construction des médias occidentaux où
il y avait vraiment un enjeu pour
vladimir poutine il ya un enjeu dans la
mesure où la date du 9 mai beaucoup plus
importantes en russie que la dette du
vie mais les importantes en europe c'est
que la date de la victoire est beaucoup
plus commémoré parce qu'il ya un récit
qui a été fait nous la réconciliation
est passé et depuis quand même des
années y compris avant la guerre contre
l'ukraine l'a bien sûr ils
instrumentalisent en faisant un
parallèle entre la victoire de 45 et la
victoire de 2022 mais avant même qu'il y
ait une guerre contre l'ukraine le 9 mai
a toujours été un moment beaucoup plus
important en russie que du temps y
compris après la fin de l'union
soviétique dont c'est une date
importante sauf quand un de succès il
peut pas montré grand chose et donc
effectivement on pouvait penser qu'il
aurait pu espérer une porte de sortie
alors ils auraient puisse dire voilà
j'ai marioupol est encore lusinchi
raison enfin bon la ville est conquise
mais en fait il ne peut pas montré grand
chose et le pire est peut être à venir
pour lui parce que le rapport des forces
militaires n'est pas tellement en sa
faveur il y a plus de réserves du côté
ukrainien du fait de l'aide massive des
états unis et de l'aide importante des
pays européens qu'il n'ya de réserve du
côté russe et donc effectivement c'est
joli de défilés on montre sa force alors
à chaque fois un défi limité à seillans
regarder comment les puits sont aussi
bien ses citoyens que aux étrangers mais
oui c'est scier temps on pourrait
reprendre ce que disait coup de chefs d
etats unis c'est un tigre de papier
milanais dans atomique donc
effectivement
l'armée russe n'est pas tout à fait
opérationnel pour gagner une guerre
conventionnelle mais il y a quand même
la dissuasion qui joue mais beaucoup
d'observateurs s'accordent à dire que
c'est vladimir poutine qui lui même a
voulu faire de ce 9 mai une date
incontournable en aussi davantage que
ses prédécesseurs c'est lui qui a
instrumentalisé aussi cette date afin de
glorifier son propre pouvoir oui c'est
très intéressant l'histoire de cette
date and le héros me corrigera si on le
trouve un peu c'est que au fond en 45
staline il ya le fameux défilé dont on a
tous vu des images du en 1945 de cette
fameuse parade de la victoire où on voit
notamment le général jock of the grand
disons héros de cette guerre des filets
sur son cheval blanc etc et c'est vrai
que après staline qui ne veut pas être
finalement absorbé par finalement le
récit de la guerre mais qu'il veut que
construire en fait ce qu'il veut
construire au niveau du pays où ont
poussé le pays en avant et surtout qui a
très peur de l'influencé militaire se
débarrasse de cette date et il n'y a
plus de parades pendant tout le reste de
l'air staline et sous khrouchtchev non
plus et sous khrouchtchev on a
vision en fait de la guerre qui changent
puisqu'on a le dégel on a toute la
littérature
si vous voulez du dégel de tous les
dissidents ou de tous ces grands
écrivains russes qui commence à parler
au monde un du drame du malheur de
l'horreur et donc des destins
individuels vous avez tous ces récits
extraordinaires qui vont sortir dans la
littérature russe donc c'est une période
où lula la guerre les gens se rejoignent
finalement dans une sorte de communion
du malheur et s'est plus jamais ça et
est ce qui est intéressant c'est que
sous brejnev il ya une brejnev ce
s'essoufflant sur le plan idéologique on
rentre dans une période où il ya une
sorte de désillusion totale sur le
l'avenir radieux du communisme et donc
staline original décide d'utiliser en
fait là le 9 mai comme élément de
ralliement de la population et vous avez
80000 monument à la mémoire de la guerre
qui sont créés sur de glorification et
poutine après vous avez avoir la
pérestroïka eltsine c'est plutôt la
critique en fait les parades existent ou
à nous de toujours mais c'est plutôt la
critique des crimes du communisme les
pages noires même de cette guerre dont
on commence à parler il ya des films il
ya des récits et est finalement poutine
arrivé lui il veut immédiatement trouvé
un moyen de ressouder cette russie veut
pas qu'elle fasse face à ces crimes ou
en tout cas il ne veut pas totalement
galles face et donc peu à peu ils
s'engouffrent là dedans sur l'idée qu'on
est une nation glorieuse alors justement
laetitia c'est intéressant c'est aussi
on l'a titré comme ça ce débat une
guerre pour la mémoire oui vous avez
même parler de révisionnisme pour
introduire notre discussion et c'est
vrai que l'on parle de guerre militaire
de guerre de communication depuis le 24
février mais il y a si la guerre des
faits c'est à dire qu'elle fait seront
inscrits dans les manuels d'histoire
alors je ne suis pas naïve je sais bien
que à travers le monde les manuels ont
leur propre récit selon les pays mais
tout de même thomas je souhaitais en
fait ce soir vous vous interpeller sur
les conditions du maintien du dialogue
diplomatique quand vladimir poutine ce
matin dit cela
tout laissait penser qu'un affrontement
avec les néo nazis
les nationalistes sur lesquels mise et
les etats-unis et leurs petits amis
seraient inévitables
bien sûr ils parlent sous couvert de la
menace c'est ce sont ses mots de l'otan
qui serait l'agresseur les à l'agresseur
finalement de de la russie alors pour
ceux vous aviez aussi qui souhaitait une
clarification des intentions de vladimir
poutine à ces ratés et justement
entretenir ce flou artistique fait peser
semble-t-il davantage la menace sur les
occidentaux et donc je vous pose la
question de l'avenir en fait le dialogue
diplomatique puisque c'est la position
de la présidence macron le dialogue
diplomatique avec vladimir poutine quand
nous avons deux systèmes de pensée de
vision des faits de la réalité
historique même totalement opposée est
ce que le lien n'est que symbolique
finale
alors poutine a coupé tous les ponts
avec le monde occidental il a renoncé au
monde occidental il pense que les
occidentaux sont fondamentalement contre
la russie il en veut aux occidentaux
d'avoir compromis la russie donc il a
effectivement coupé tous les ponts et il
est bien nippon qui existent sont
coupées ce discours est une sorte pas de
dernier clou dans le cercueil des
relations entre la russie et l'occident
mais un petit peu quand même ceci étant
par réalisme il faudra toujours
maintenir un contact parce que si on
veut que ces combats cessent ces biens
et poutine qui devra le négocier donc il
faut maintenir une ligne ouverte au cas
où sans avenir beaucoup d'illusions mais
cette réalité pas pardon interne sata
réalité parallèle finalement dont on
parle est ce que l'annuaire poutine a
fini par y croire
à ces assauts de plus on arrive à croire
ses propres mensonges on est toujours
prisonnier sa propre propagande y serait
pas étonnant qu'à force de le répéter il
en soit lui-même auto convaincu mais en
tous les cas beaucoup de russes
entendent cela ceci étant on sait très
bien qu'il ya les discours et puis il
peut tout à fait changer de discours si
demain il a intérêt à avoir un cessez le
feu il trouve un lot discours et on
n'acceptera pas ce que c'est notre
intérêt d'avoir un cessez le feu
absolument c'est je pense que des on a
finalement longtemps pensé et c'est
peut-être pour ça d'ailleurs que pour la
plupart je crois des observateurs ne
pensais pas qu'il y aurait une attaque
de cette ampleur le 24 février parce
qu'on imaginait toujours une forme de
rationalité de effectivement vladimir
poutine voyant ses intérêts et sachant
toujours ne pas aller trop loin comme il
l'avait fait en géorgie par exemple en
2008 comme il n'avait finalement pas
reconnue alors jusqu'au 21 février les
républiques séparatistes lnr dnr donc on
imaginait - mes interlocuteurs en
ukraine jusqu'à la veille du conflit
imaginer qu'il se contenterait sans
doute d'une incursion dans le dos de
bath mais que finalement ils n'iraient
pas plus loin et avec il y aurait une
sorte de décalage entre la l'énormité du
discours notamment ce discours justement
fleuve du 21 février qui nie tout
historicité finalement à et toute
identité à l'ukraine pendant 12 ans il
n'emploie pas le mot une crème dans son
discours non et d'ukraine n'existe pas
en fait la ligue et en plus l'ukraine
est une création de lénine alors là ce
qui serait bon qu'ils nous emmènerait un
petit peu loin il serait intéressant
pour voir justement jusqu'à jusqu'à quel
point effectivement dans le récit
historique de vladimir poutine et du
pouvoir russe qui a pas que vladimir
poutine depuis depuis des années
effectivement la la personnalité de
lénine et même la révolution de 1917 est
finalement beaucoup plus que le
stalinisme la tâche sombre qui justement
et ne permet pas complètement de dresser
ce continuum de l'histoire russe et de
ses et de ses hauts faits d'armes laure
mandeville est-ce que dans sa logique
vladimir poutine a besoin alors ces pays
pour fait ça mais de s'inventer en
permanence à un état de crise où un hulu
un ennemi qui takita voilà je reviens
vivent dans une sorte de monde parallèle
ça c'est tout à fait clair c'était ce
qu'il y à une continuité entre
évidente en fait entre ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur de la société russe et ce
qui se passe à l'extérieur c'est à dire
que le pouvoir est un le pouvoir qui est
entré dans une logique dictatoriale et
qui a besoin de trouver des moyens de
justifier finalement la poursuite de cet
écrasement de tous les contre-pouvoirs à
l'intérieur de son propre pays et donc
la seule manière de mener si vous voulez
de ressouder derrière lui c'est de
trouver un ennemi extérieur est
d'ailleurs intérieur parce qu'il parle
et vous avez vu hier d'ailleurs il parle
en permanence il a dit aussi aujourd'hui
de l'ennemi de l'intérieur qu'il faut
aussi traqué et et donc il s'est en
effet inventé cet ennemi e néonazis et
derrière lequel il ya évidemment
l'occident qui fait partie en fait de
cette menace nazie que c'est ce qu'il
dit est donc si vous voulez on est dans
une situation lotion absolument je
dirais surréaliste et indécente aussi
puisque il utilise la seconde guerre
mondiale et disons le combat en fait de
du peuple soviétique dont faisait partie
d'ailleurs avec des bataillons énorme en
proportion les ukrainiens pour si vous
voulez ressusciter le spectre de la
menace nazie alors qu'au fond comme le
dit garry kasparov récemment c'est
plutôt les russes aujourd'hui qu'ils se
comportent comme des fascistes qu'il ya
cette inversion si vous voulez
absolument
terrifiante mais il y avait un truc je
voulais dire c'est que ce qui est
intéressant c'est que au fond
quand on regarde ça on se dit mais c'est
incroyable on était en 91 dans les
retrouvailles
cette espèce d'euphorie que nous avons
tous eu cet espoir d'ailleurs partagé
par tellement de russes qu'ils allaient
rejoindre finalement l'occident et puis
on regarder où nous en sommes cette
parade on se croirait en union
soviétique avec un putin vieillissant
entouré de généraux bardé de décorations
comme si comme si 80 enfin la chute du
mur 80 ou d'effondrement de l'urss était
une sorte de parenthèse fallait gommer
la et donc le 8 go home et des trente
ans puisqu'il dit y'a pas eu
d'indépendance ukrainienne il veut
ressusciter il il dresse des statues de
lénine à carson dans les territoires
qu'ils libèrent il s'agit des drapeaux
rouges donc si vous voulez c'est comme
si ses 30 ans n'avait pas existé la
seule chose qui change me semble-t-il on
est toujours dans le monde songe la
propagande comme à l'époque soviétique
ce qui change c'est le côté très
inquiétant d'un pouvoir sans garde-fou
vous parliez de la rationalité on va on
va y revenir ça parce que c'est
évidemment les questions tic notamment
avec la menace nucléaire mais vous vous
évoquiez effectivement ce c'est
totalement indécent pour nous d'entendre
le discours de vladimir poutine mais
encore plus pour les ukrainiens et c'est
ce que mettait en avant volodymyr
zelensky hier puisqu'il a lui choisi
évidemment la date du 8 mai pour
commémorer la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale et les sacrifices du peuple
ukrainien casillas à bord a réussi à
oublier tout ce qui était important pour
les vainqueurs de la deuxième guerre
mondiale la grippe kendal aborder les
frappes de missiles sur odessa et nos
autres villes sont imitation de la façon
dont les nazis ont essayé de bombarder
et de détruire les villes européennes
par les bombardements
pascal boniface on l'a déjà évoqué ici
mais je trouve que dans cette journée du
9 mai c'est important de le dire rares
sont ceux
même peut-être parmi les observateurs
qui imaginaient une telle résistance du
peuple ukrainien et on peut aller
jusqu'à la dîmière poutine évidemment
dans la liste de ce qu'ils n'imaginaient
pas ballet compris zelensky lui-même je
pense que t'être donc effectivement
toute personne n'aurait pu imaginer une
telle faiblesse de l'armée russe une
telle force de l'armée ukrainienne et
une telle unité du monde occidental
d'aia l'ukraine et c'est ces trois
facteurs qui expliquent la quasi défaite
militaire russe parce qu ils sont
embourbés on pouvait prévoir assez vite
tu aurais un bourbier parce que il
n'avait que deux cent mille hommes et on
peut pas occuper un pays de 40 millions
d'habitants avec deux cent mille hommes
donc dès le départ cette affaire était
mal parti pour eux mais là effectivement
il faut encore le rapport de force
changé par rapport aux restrictions de
libertés auxquelles leur bonne ville
faisait allusion tout à l'heure ce qui
est encore plus grave à long terme pour
la russie c'est l'exode de toutes les
forces vives du pays
tous les gens qui notamment d'ailleurs
travaillent dans des secteurs de la
technologie des nouvelles forces des
nouvelles technologies de l'information
de la communication
ils n'ont aucune envie ils ont un peu
goûté au monde extérieur aux contacts
extérieurs ils n'ont aucune envie de
vivre dans un régime stalinien parce que
c'est un retour à staline c'est un
retour à staline en terme de nos
relations entre l'est et l'ouest et
c'est un retour à staline en termes de
privation de liberté donc il y à une
fuite et des forces vives du pays qui va
coûter à terme très très chiant à
poutine or dans ces emprunts et ses
minoritaires comme là c'est quand même
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
depuis ils sont très compétents ils
poutine s'en félicite de ce que c'est
des opposants moi mais je dis en fait il
peut avoir un scénario il dit le pays
est affaibli finalement kim jong-eun est
toujours à la tête de la corée du nord
et bachar el-assad est toujours en tête
de la syrie et donc on affaiblit deux
pays les eaux ceux qui sont pas contents
s'en vont mais ça pour la russie c'est
quand même poutine qui le premier avait
dit celui qui maîtrisera l'intelligence
très visuel maîtrisera le monde est
vraiment en est déficitaire un sociaux
la question se pose qui vient de façon
assez évidente du point de vue
occidental évidemment c'est ces
personnes les élites qui quitte la
russie pour ne pas être enfants enfermés
dans ce système stalinien pourquoi sans
qu'à nice tel pas en résistance à
vladimir poutine puisque elles en ont
les peut-être les moyens en tout cas
intellectuels et les connexions
certainement pour déstabiliser ce
pouvoir ne
oui les connexions sans doute il ya
vraisemblablement un certain nombre de
contacts qui sont menées par par des
opposants qui sont qui ont déjà quitté
le pays en fait est ce que ce phénomène
de fuite de cerveaux et de fuite des
opposants politiques des journalistes
indépendants des militants etc n'est pas
tout à fait nouveau et avait déjà eu un
mouvement en 2011 2012 après les grandes
manifestations
depuis en fait ils et les démographes
essaye de traquer des statistiques parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui partent
tout en gardant un enregistrement
officiel en russie dont qui continue à
compter dans la population russe alors
qu'en fait ils n'y sont plus et qu il ne
trahit travaille en réalité à
l'extérieur ou bien qui travaille depuis
l'extérieur pour des petites sociétés
d'informatique effectivement et sur les
savoirs de poutine sur son isolement que
sait-on de son idole ans est sans doute
difficile de répondre à la question oui
alors ça je moi je ben oui ça c'est
vraiment la boîte noire je pense absolue
et du fait qu'ils soient sans doute
qu'on voyait que tout le plus le temps
passe et plus il est
vraisemblablement isolés y compris de
son entourage proche qui est d'ailleurs
peut-être finalement à a peur de lui de
lui dire où à eu peur de lui dire de ce
qui allait se passer en ukraine mais en
tout cas pour finir sur la question de
l'opposition et de la guerre il se passe
plein de plein de petites choses dans la
dent dans la société russe cdc
extrêmement ténus c'est extrêmement
risqué courageux difficile mais il ya
des dizaines et des dizaines de chaînes
télégramme tous les jours qui montrent
des actions de protestation une femme
qui ce qui secoue la bouche
avec avec un fil des des no tamment un
groupe de féministes russe qui
aujourd'hui ont fait tout un tas de
pancartes des tournées avec le 9 mai
mais des images des villes bombardées
d'ukraine voilà on voit des beaucoup
d'avocats de juristes qui se met au
service des jeunes qui veulent refusé le
service de service militaire donc
évidemment tout ça ne fait pas les 80 %
de l'opinion qu'ils sont supposés
soutenir la l'opération militaire mais
c'est quand même important de savoir que
ça existe encore y compris à l'intérieur
on va continuer de parler de du pouvoir
de vladimir poutine de son isolement
éventuelles sur la question de la menace
nucléaire
et c'est donc une réaction que je vous
propose tout de suite celle de christian
cambon qui est président de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées ici au
sénat il était notre invité sur la
chaîne ce matin à écouter ce qui nous
dit de cette menace nucléaire moi je
défends la crainte selon laquelle selon
le syndrome du chien enragé ou fond de
l'impasse qui ne voyaient aucune
solution se retourne et vous mort et
donc rien n'est exclu a priori même si
personne ne le souhaite rien exclu
l'utilisation d'armes encore plus
dangereuse je pensais à des armes
tactiques
sous nucléaire sous la barre de ce qui a
été malheureusement fait et hiroshima
mais qui peuvent faire effectivement
beaucoup de beaucoup de morts ce serait
évidemment un changement complet dans la
situation espérons que là la raison
l'emportera mais avec quelqu'un comme le
président russe actuellement on commence
à s'interroger vraiment le syndrome je
retiens cette cette expression le
syndrome du chien enragé dans l'impasse
à ce que dit le sénateur cambon à propos
de la lumière poutine oui c'est vrai que
vous avez eue hier en fait une
déclaration en fait une sorte de
conférence du chef de la cia y est vous
avez william burns aux états unis qui a
aussi évoqué cette question et qui a dit
qu'il y avait une inquiétude sur ce
sujet même si même si il faut quand même
aussi se méfier de cet épouvantail parce
que
vladimir poutine en fait a toujours misé
sur la peur des occidentaux sur leur
manque de courage sur leurs faiblesses
et je pense qu'il continue à travers ce
chantage nucléaire à le faire pour lui
le rêve c'est évidemment des avancées
militaires sous la menace d'une frappe
nucléaire c'est à dire il faut faire
très attention à ne pas être tétanisé
par cette question du nucléaire parce
que à part si on accepte que il vitrifie
d'ukraine ou non de la menace nucléaire
ça veut dire qu'on prépare la suite que
demain parce qu'on aura peur de répondre
ils puissent entrer en dans les pays
baltes en disant hé ben sinon il y aura
une apocalypse nucléaire et donc vous
voyez bien que cette question là est
utilisé comme un chantage
un opposant russe mikhaïl khodorkovski
vous savez qui a passé dix ans en prison
qui est un des principaux opposants à
vladimir poutine récemment souligné qu'
il faudrait quand même pour que monsieur
poutine
se décide à appuyer sur le bouton ce qui
peut toujours être forcé de faire s'il
est malade qu'est ce qu'il le fasse une
forme de référendum auprès de ses
généraux parce que si vous savez très
bien que s'ils appuient sur le bouton ça
n'envoie pas le feu nucléaire ça ça
envoie un
ordre aux généraux russes et est ce que
vladimir poutine aujourd'hui veut faire
en effet référendum parmi ses généraux
pour savoir s'ils sont ou non prêt à
mourir avec lui et à déclencher une
frappe nucléaire ça c'est une première
chose et il faudrait qu'il fasse un
deuxième référendum disait cet opposant
a vis-à-vis des occidentaux où il est
face à des occidentaux qui si on en
appuyer ont décidé de lancer le feu
nucléaire pourrait renvoyer le feu
nucléaire donc là aussi est ce qu'il me
veut vraiment se lancer dans ce type de
référendum aussi vis-à-vis de l'occident
pascal boniface si on remonte un peu
dans le temps le cette menace nucléaire
justement dans les discours de vladimir
poutine
est-ce qu'ils l'utilisent si souvent que
ça ou est ce qu'il le laisse à d'autres
non il l'a utilisée il a simplement fait
rappeler que la russie a des armes
nucléaires est d'une évidence et les
généraux ont rappelé la doctrine de
dissuasion qui est que s'il n'ya pas
atteinte aux intérêts essentiels
existentielle de la russie la larme
nucléaire et joue donc en fait on peut
penser que la menace et ne venez pas en
russie ne cherchez pas à me déloger du
pouvoir vous faites une comparaison est
cuite l'air mais je ne mourrai pas dans
mon bunker et vous ne viendrez pas à
moscou pour faire un changement de
régime je vois mal mais on peut se
tromper poutine utilisez larmes il ya
comme une arme de combat parce que là je
vois plus quels sont les pays qui
pourraient encore le suivre qu y compris
la chine l'inde et les quelques pays qui
n'ont pas encore coupé les ponts parce
qu'il
franchirait un tabou absolument
essentiel est la même les pays qui pour
l'instant pour des raisons multiples et
variées n'ont pas coupé les ponts avec
lui ne pourrait pas continuer d'avoir
des relations plus comme vous l'avez dit
le fait que les généraux dirons nous
c'est pas notre problème de mourir avec
vous donc mais par contre la grc part
dans un camping à 7 contre pouvoir quand
même puis fonctionne encore parce que
vise une procédure qui fait qu' on se
garde quand même de l'être humain et que
dans tous les pays où il y a l'arme
nucléaire et il suffit pas de se lever
d'un mauvais pied pour comme on dit
appuyer sur le bouton
normalement il ya aidiez à 3-3 il sait à
la décision se prend à 3 et puis l'autre
quand même qu'il ya aussi ceux qui sont
opérationnels etc mais disons que
poutine a effectivement intérêt à ce que
la dissuasion c'est pas tellement être
sûr de frapper l'autre c'est que l'autre
pense que vous qu'il peut être super et
donc on est effectivement dissuader
sociétés ont pour l'instant le problème
c'est qu'on voit pas quelle est l'issue
militaire de cette guerre on ne sait pas
quelles sont à partir de quand les
ukrainiens pourront dire qu'ils ont
récupéré leur territoire et on voit pas
10 le dombass la grille mais ça me
paraît là pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
sortie de crise qui permette et à
poutine et à l'ukraine de sortir la tête
haute et donc c'est ce qu'ont promis
qu'il faudrait trouver d'ailleurs à nos
héros dans son discours le maire poutine
aujourd'hui il a il a fait référence à
la vidéo des sacrés par l'impératrice
catherine ii sais c'est quoi ces on peut
imaginer que parce que là quand même un
peu annoncé les étapes dans ses
différents discours iban
d'offres
raciste est une expression qui datent de
cette époque là justement et de la
conquête effectifs ça veut dire quoi ça
nouvelle russie donc c'est bien c'est au
nom de cette nova racicot un certain
nombre de deux personnes je pense
notamment à ce traikov alias gherkin
sont allés se battre dans le dôme basse
en espérant bien aller au delà de
lougansk à donetsk concret hier marie
gopaul puis aller jusqu'à odessa et
pourquoi pas faire la jonction avec la
transnistrie d'ailleurs des propos qui
sont rappelées régulièrement par les
généraux justement ces dernières ces
dernières semaines donc cette idée alors
moi je suis pas spécialisé géopolitique
mais on parle de cette fameuse et ça
c'est aussi une histoire us cet accès
aux mers chaudes le fait de s'approprier
effectivement l'ensemble du littoral
évidemment les enjeux aussi commerciaux
autour de l'exportation de céréales et
de grains et là aussi ça joue y compris
sur les quelques soutiens que peu dont
peut bénéficier la russie dans les pays
dans les pays du sud évidemment puisque
la russie a réussi effectivement ces
dernières années à s'assurer un certain
nombre de marchés
je pense à des marchés sur le blé
notamment et donc l'idée à l'ukraine est
aussi un grand exportateur dont idée de
vouloir s'approprier aussi ses marchés
ou de vouloir empêcher l'ukraine de
continuer à exporter ça fait partie
aussi alors en plus de ce qui se passe
autour de gaz et du pétrole mais ça fait
aussi partie d'une d'une arme qu'on
utilise la plus tant à destination de
l'occident qu'à destination de du global
ça on pourrait dire voilà de cp je peux
dire quelque chose alors disent
maintenant oui je vais me semblait en
fait que quand pascal boniface parle en
fait du compromis qu'il faut trouver moi
je pense qu'il faut bien comprendre que
des deux côtés on est dans une dans un
combat je dirais à mort c'est à dire que
les ukrainiens ont compris que vladimir
poutine représente un péril mortel
puisque lui il nie l'existence de
l'ukraine ce qu'il veut c'est une
capitulation donc les pour les
ukrainiens la guerre durera tant qu'on
n'aura pas
comment dire soit mis à bas ce régime
soit en tout cas
bouté bouter l'ennemi russe hors du
territoire merci est resté avec nous
comme promis je vous propose un nouveau
rendez vous dans ce sens public sur
public sénat chaque semaine une séquence
destinées aux réfugiés ukrainien ils
sont soixante quinze mille à être passé
dans notre pays cinquante mille ont déjà
un titre de séjour provisoire
marion vigreux va nous rejoindre tout de
suite vous allez à la fois donner des
informations sur la guerre sur le statut
des droits des ukrainiens dans notre
pays et on commence tout de suite
premier titre la prise de parole de
volodymyr zelensky c'était ce matin en
amont du discours de vladimir poutine
reste aux pauvres de
maputo
effectivement dans un clip posté ce
matin sur les réseaux sociaux on
découvre le chef de l'état ukrainien qui
marche dans kiev et y s'exprime ou face
caméra pendant près de cinq minutes en
réponse aux cérémonies russe organisée
ce lundi 9 mai pour célébrer la fin de
la seconde guerre mondiale il évoque à
grand renfort d'image de parade
militaire ukrainienne l'anniversaire de
l'indépendance de son pays mais il
rappelle également que les ukrainiens
ont aussi lutter contre le nazisme et
accuse vladimir poutine de répéter les
mêmes créé ma vie de
la part
de
robin et viennent pour cela être sauna
cadre vescovo par hadopi trouve à
nouveau toutes nos
vidéos et augusto
il est celui qui répète aujourd'hui les
crimes horribles du régime hitlérien
suivant la philosophie nazis copiant ce
qu'ils ont fait en conséquence il perdra
tout y est très vite nous célébrerons
deux jours de la victoire en ukraine et
certains n'ont plus qu'un seul nous les
vaincrons alors nous gagnerons nous
aussi cher et kiev vers à la parade de
la victoire l'ukraine victorieuse
célébrant la victoire sur le nazisme la
loire à l'ukraine
président zelensky dont une intervention
est prévue en france ce mercredi 11 mai
à 13h il s'adressera en direct pendant
60 minutes aux étudiants de plusieurs
universités françaises comme sciences po
l'inalco paris 1 panthéon sorbonne il
répondra également aux questions des
étudiants cet échange sera diffusé en
ligne ce
projet national
de 25 ans je vis dans un petit
bout de temps
pour revenir aux commémorations de la
fin de la seconde guerre mondiale ce
lundi l'ambassadeur russe en pologne a
été aspergée d'une substance rouge est
pris à partie par des manifestants pro
ukrainien il déposait une gerbe au
cimetière de varsovie en hommage aux
soldats soviétiques lorsqu'il a été pris
à partie d'autres journaux ce fait
comment une très mauvaise ou et avait ni
trépané du rock pour son récit
autobiographique
où
le crédit au coeur des discussions ce
lundi au parlement européen puisque nous
célébrons aujourd'hui la journée de
l'europe dans son discours le président
français qui assure jusqu'au mois de
juin la présidence du conseil de lune
européenne a rappelé son soutien à
l'ukraine dénoncer les crimes commis par
les russes qu'ils seront poursuivis et
évoqué son espoir d'une fin rapide du
conflit
aucune attaque au centre de secours de
diallo a menti sur
tout comme
révoqué ou resto pop
pour que cette guerre prenne fin nous
avons adopté des chops avait
probablement
les sources de la star au covan
finances sauvage et veillait au grain
nous sommes vraiment au nord dans moyens
même les variantes nikon reaches nevis
corée entre nice et rennes monument
et enfin pour terminer cette information
pratique les réfugiés ukrainien
bénéficiant à de la protection
temporaire vont pouvoir suivre jusqu'à
400 heures de français à compter de ce
lundi une évaluation décidera de leur
répartition par niveau objectif leur
permettent de maîtriser les bases de la
langue française pour pouvoir notamment
envisager une activité professionnelle
il n'a plus qu'une si le format rack
trop aux craintes il ya comme dans notre
france
tu te recoudre de noro qui feront tout
ce qu on en arrive
à une boîte de
vitesses
automatique les chambres au chat sauvage
merci merci marion merci olga aussi qui
se chargeait de 7
traduction voilà la solidarité de public
sénat envers les réfugiés d'ukrainiens
marqué par cet objet télévisuel un peu
particulier et c'était important de le
faire merci à tous d'avoir participé à
ce débat lors mandil révolte et
d'occident ces petits tours de votre
livre qui est publié aux édition de
l'observatoire pascal boniface la
géopolitique tout simplement c'est
publié chez eyrolles voilà merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat